but we wanted to see if these people
would put their money where their mouth
says because they protest the government
they want the government to bring in
refugees so not Kay Jarrod had the
brilliant idea we called many of these
progressive churches to see well you can
take a look for yourself
Hart House is this Christa hi Christa
how are you today I'm good how are you
I'm doing well thank you very much um my
name is grant Mayo I'm with the
Institute for saving immigrants from
Syria and I wanted to know if there was
someone there with whom I could speak
regarding just sort of partnership we
are asking for no money
I represent refugee Affairs placement
enterprise and we're just looking for
compassionate progressive Christian
allies well I'm actually calling from
the the justice for immigration
humanitarian aid division my name is
grant may owe me a little more sure my
name is grant Merrill I'm with the
Bureau of United transatlantic transit
for understanding caring and kindness
it's an organization that deals
currently right now with the refugee
crisis and with a search online your
church showed up as just truly a beacon
of progress and compassion and we wanted
to see who we could speak was there and
partnering up and and providing as well
as receiving some assistance your church
is very public about your your
progressivism correct yeah thank you
well it's just very impressive it's it's
very christ-like to open the doors you
know wide open without so much as
security clearance we've seen online
about the current refugee situation and
the need to help them I think we're both
on board with that correct yeah okay so
how many can I put you down for I don't
have to get back with you on that well I
mean time is of the essence we have some
people here who've obviously come over
you know on planes and some by land some
by sea land or sea air foam correct you
know just want to see how many you can
house there at your church we quietly
don't have the you know space for room
to ask them in out but I would have to
do that some people would surely you
know have to discuss and see if we can
make provisions for that and give you a
call back okay but you do you have
supported taking in refugees correct
I don't want to be honorable no not he
not no here no in the church knowing
okay but you have in general that being
compassionate yes yes yeah just not in
your church nothing just my nachos so we
have to like you know put in provision
for that really quickly what about you
yourself how many refugees have have you
taken in I haven't taken any oh well
that's perfect we have to right now
we're ready to go they're fantastic
they're very friendly I don't have to
space any capacity right now you don't
have space you don't have space in your
heart well I want to make sure off the
bat though I'm not mistaken and
understanding that church is a
progressive Church correct let me ask
you before we before I give you my
information how many refugees have you
house there at the church we're trying
to take a little bit of a of a survey
here and we don't house them within the
church building do you know anyone there
who has anyone who is personally taken
one into their home or a church
personally whose houses them like I say
we don't that's not what we do here sure
know that we did we expected beauty no
no we wouldn't expect you to do that but
but speaking out in support of it is
certainly almost the same thing yeah I'm
not sure what you're asking well we have
I know the Church's position has been to
support the helping of the needy and
refugees and we have refugee elementary
children who we are bringing again
justice for immigration humanitarian aid
division and since that is your
department at the church I would just
like to know you know how many we could
we could bring in there that you can
help well I'll tell you what my
philosophy is I don't turn anybody away
sure so and if there's something that we
program that we offer that that anybody
would be interested in you know we'll be
happy to help in any way we can
sure so like housing we need to help man
well we need to house refugee children
we need a place to live no we well
I have I have no air no inkling on how
to approach anything like that at all I
know it's very simple you open your door
and your heart oh well yeah my position
here is to provide Faith Formation
programs for children and families sure
sure sure so how many can we put your
department down for you need to come
here for Faith Formation yes and for
Faith Formation certainly and you know
food shelter sleeping bags if you have
them I can handle the part about Faith
Formation but sure about it but what
better social services program than the
body of Christ I mean that's that's the
goal and all of us what I'm saying is we
don't have a facility here where people
can can sleep and shower and eat and
stuff like that oh you don't have
bathrooms there no well we have we have
restrooms but they're in the school well
perfect there you go there's room in the
school you have right try that I
understand believe me I understand where
you're coming from it is not without its
concern for the other children obviously
when we're talking about assimilation
and and and some of these children
frankly act out very violently do you
know if the church has taken in at least
as I call back down my list has this
because there's nowhere to put them
what about the homes of the pastors or
yourself do you have room for a small
child in your heart you know what this
is really a good idea for us to talk
about here yeah we're not doing anything
today but maybe this is something we
should talk about absolutely yeah why
don't you call me back in a couple of
weeks and hopefully I'll you know see
what I can do oh but they'll be deported
by then that's the issue is with the
immigration ban right now you know there
isn't anybody here right now today for
me to talk to you know answer this death
this child just wants someone to talk to
it's like her name is again my name is
Grant Mayo with the justice for
immigration humanitarian aid division
okay yeah that's me om e oh not some
people think like mayonnaise and they
shorten it and that's just grossly
offensive but even you don't listen if
it's temporary if if you were or just a
member who's there
now that's you know an extra cot there's
no one here for me to run this through
to get approval sure no but I mean
individuals you can just start calling
down the list and see if people have
room that's what we're looking for right
yeah I would have to get permission to
be able to do that sure you need
permission from your husband q well
let's let's get him on the line I mean
listen these these kids come from a very
patriarchal society they'd be very
understanding yeah thank you it's great
to have social programs but obviously
these these these people need a place to
live and and resettle you know there's
no after-school program for somebody who
doesn't even have a house to to to take
a bus from to school you understand
right we just serve the children here
okay so you serve the children well I
just so happen to have children ages 4
and 13 13s at that problem age you know
but but good kids really good kids end
up we we need to find a place for them
what about you yourself or you know
we've opened our houses personally we
know people have been calling for this
we're just looking for true progressives
to open their their homes and hearts is
that something you'd consider I am NOT
in a place to do that right now why not
I'm a student and I am about to get
married and so that's not something that
I could do but there is another what you
do you you do encourage others to do so
most definitely yes okay so it's you do
it so you're we're on board other people
should be doing this you're just you're
naturally you're getting married and
you're students so you can't do it right
now okay you know the problem is a 13
year old here madula among gada cannot
cannot wait because he may be shipped
right back you know there are people
who've been I'm sure you've heard about
the ban the crisis where they've come
here and they may have to go back if
they're from the seven countries and I
mean we need to resettle them now you
know we don't have time for someone to
call us back two weeks in and and then
you know offer them offer them you know
some intramural basketball
okay well I'm sorry we're definitely not
the place for that hi this is Melissa
I'm the operations manager what is it
that you need hi Melissa how are you
today I'm good thank you
this is grant mail with the Institute
for saving immigrants from Syria and we
work to resettle refugees we have just
been coming up against a dead end
Melissa we have been trying to get these
poor people coming from war-torn
countries refugees many of whom are
still you know middle-aged males into
homes here and there are a lot of
organizations who have extracurricular
activities who have support groups but
we need homes and we wouldn't be able to
do any of that what about you Melissa do
you have a spare bedroom no I don't
really even if it's just you know for a
temporary amount of time anyone in your
family or any of your friends
what about anyone on the organization
anyone there who could actually open I
mean I have four right now
and believe me I've rescued animals as
well you know and and I am my home is
just a revolving door of people who need
help it's not without its problems you
know my daughter's weren't huge fans for
a little while but it has been a very
rewarding experience and I and I get it
because like I said we work with our
kids who are refugees so we've heard a
horse tour and we've heard everything I
mean that's where our heart and our
passion lies so what were stories we
understand that it's a crisis situation
emergency situations like I said our
organization doesn't do anything like
that no no not the organization just any
of the people there and but since you
called our organization you can't really
ask me on a personal level or my family
if we can open our home so you could try
like residential or individual
personal numbers there was a place for
that since we're nonprofit sure they
know sure you I hope I hope you have a
lot of luck with this your search sounds
like you're doing really rewarding
things you're not getting anything done
no one will take these people and I wish
I could say the same
thank know if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
Internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit com / mug club members
of your student military or veteran
internet promo code it's less than six
dollars a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand at
smug oh I just when I feel it I got a
chill like on the inside